i'm very happy to be sitting next to
international master eric rosen eric
welcome to the show oh thanks
i think this is the first time we've
ever done this together i think so yeah
it feels pretty surreal to be here
i feel bad kicking away dorsa from your
seat but uh i feel bad that you kicked
away
as well but it's very nice to have you
uh obviously you're a local and for
folks who don't know you um
international master and
i think you do a great job with your
stream really a big shout out to you
no no no it's really really good for
those of you don't know and address our
audience if you will tell us what you
got right
about this candidates and your
predictions oh dear i've uh well i've
been doing like these uh like the
chess.com channel point predictions uh
at the start of each broadcast ask every
day how many draws there will be
and i i usually predict like three or
four draws but there's been so many
rounds with uh three we were more
decisive games so it's it's been a
thrill to watch
and very difficult to predict um i think
in the beginning i i really thought favi
would have a uh a
good shot of coming on top and right
okay he was in the
two of our top two for a while felt the
same way
uh varusian and uh christian both picked
fabi
in fact as their uh top picks and
only dorset got nephi but she came in a
week late
it was unfair that she got to pick
when the tournament was half uh
over
gary kasparov made a very salient point
that
he should have
known that nepal was going to be
successful
because of his training that he had at
the world championship match he's
carrying all of the ideas and all of the
enthusiasm and the energy
that he wasn't able to demonstrate in
dubai and that's true that that carried
him very well
for this event
did nepo's
nepo's success surprise you
um in hindsight i think it's less
surprising given that he's just so well
prepared in the opening and i think the
change in the time format also uh
helped him a little bit because he's one
of the quicker players of uh of the
field exactly and he's putting his
opponents under like serious pressure uh
right out of the opening and there's so
many games where his opponents are
making of unprovoked mistakes
where uh they feel the pressure on the
clock and from very early in the game so
uh
i think it's easy to say in hindsight
but yeah
yeah big kudos to him just taking a
massive lead and looks like he's about
to clinch it today no question about it
as he plays quickly puts pressure on his
opponent we have a colleague in madrid
anastasia
who caught up with magnus carlsen i'll
get your reactions to this interview
[Music]
magnus what are your comments about this
candidate's tournament and jan's
performance in particular
he's playing very well uh he's
making the most of his his chances
like uh
there have been many interesting games
but he's
converted all of his advantages very
well uh and saved bad positions so he's
been by far the best
yeah i mean did you expect it to happen
no i didn't expect it i thought he was
um
criminally underrated by um
by pundits and and betting odds but uh i
still thought uh that dean and fabiano
were even bigger favorites but kudos
he's done really well
is it going to affect somehow your
decisions to play the match or not what
do you think about it
we'll see yes okay thank you very much
for your comment
we're gonna call magnus the artful
dodger
that's right on that one as he dodged
the question by the way guys sorry to
interrupt you but speaking of
this potential world championship match
it's potentially in the books jana
pognachi has drawn his game against
richard report and that is the end of
the tournament nobody can catch nepo
officially the winner of the 2022
candidates he got his magic number
already nine points out of 13. we'll see
if he adds more tomorrow 48 000 euros
and whatever mathematical seven times
whatever points he gets
we'll play for the 2023 world
championship match we don't guarantee
it's going to be against magnus carlsen
but we do guarantee that this man janine
pomnyachi is
in it
hot tip
very very very deserving
uh alejandro was mentioning earlier that
there's actually few players just a few
players who have
been back-to-back
uh candidates winners and they include
for example vasily smislov he
he won the candidates in his first
match against uh bod vinnick ended up at
the tie and then he came comes back
to
play bobbinic again and win but then
losing a rematch
and then uh there was um
um
vishy anand
yeah who did that uh your quick take
it's quite an accomplishment i'm
actually wondering is this like a record
of the highest score in the candidates
for a 14-round event
only only um
vessel and topolof remember in the
it wasn't it was actually the world
championship in san luis argentina uh
that vessel scored six and a half
out of seven in the first half
and then you know coasted the rest away
drew drew his way to the world
championship uh title
uh but yeah that this is a
th this is a really really great score
for just draws tomorrow i believe it's
going to be the highest for candidates
you didn't mention the world
championship match
world championship
if he adds that final extra point half
point sorry
tomorrow remember he didn't do that last
time right he lost back he qualified he
was
celebrate
but dingley wren said you know what
thank you for your celebration i'll take
a full point off of you before we go
back and the question is if he's going
to be able to do so tomorrow because he
is black against duda
and if he gets at half point is the
highest ever on a 14 round double uh
round robin tournament
for the candidates but of course this is
a modern system only 10 years old
right going back to 2013. um
alejandro
your quick take on magnus the artful
dodger uh on the question of uh
anastasia asked about the match and he
said something like we'll see and then
right away i think it's what's buzzing
around social media it's what's buzzing
around the chest world ever since napo
started running away with it why because
specifically magnus said i'm not so
interested in a rematch i've already
played a bunch of these guys i'd like a
new challenge that's what he said and a
lot of people were eyeing alireza
ferrugia as that potential new blood new
challenge coming into the new generation
of chess players to challenge magnus a
lot of people thought even though magnus
is not pinpointing to anybody in the
field who could he possibly be talking
about right when he's referring to not
wanting to play the same people again i
mean nepo has to be high on that list
and that ignites this talk that we are
having right now eric what is your take
that you have all these contacts on
social media all of these streamers that
are more aware of what's going on behind
the scenes what is your take that team
magnus has in at the moment yeah i
really wish i had more inside
information um i that's why we brought
you on the show by the way so we're
putting you on the spot you don't run
out of gusts between right exactly we
sure did come on
um but yeah i think it'll be really
interesting to see and uh like even
though the
tournament is over for uh running of the
first place right um there's going to be
a very
heated fight for for second place uh as
we see hikaro still playing and i think
it would be really really cool to see
hikaru
finish in seconds
and then it creates this dynamic where
if magnus declines to play
the world championship event right
that's nicely could see a caro versus
napo world champion championship
um let's keep in mind hikaru is
primarily focused on streamer streaming
and not
competitive chess these days so that
would be uh super cool to see and i
think the fans would really enjoy that
as well quick question for you eric for
those of you for those of you who aren't
aware that eric has his own stream his
own channel
it's on twitch
yeah right yeah it's on youtube i live
stream on twitch and then post kind of
the best moments from my streams on
youtube so
uh yeah it's kind of two different
platforms that work well together and
i've been doing it for uh
it's approaching the the five year mark
um five years this fall it will be five
years gosh that goes by fast right yeah
and i got my kind of introduction to
doing online content through the st with
chess club
uh doing like the residency position and
having the the lectures being posted
online and um
yeah i really enjoyed it
the educational aspect and kind of
interacting with the community so it's
it's been super fun eric i think you do
a great job i really genuinely do
check out i am eric rosen on his uh
twitch stream twitch.tv slash i am rosie
there you go you you'll enjoy his uh
lectures his stream very very much so
like to throw to you alejandro your take
on the move knight g4 by hikaro
compensation for the pond
that's where